russland darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen das sagt der bundeskanzler und
sagt wir sind in einer zeitenwende man
gast werner schulz war bei den
bürgerrechtler der ddr
sie waren bei denen die gesagt haben
schwerter zu pflugscharen ist das was
wir jetzt erleben für sie persönlich
auch eine zeitenwende ich habe die
wendezeit und lebt und das ist jetzt ist
jetzt die zeitenwende für mich war die
zeitenwende schon der krieg in bosnien
also da habe ich gemerkt dass wir die
schule wieder brauchen dass wir nicht
alle vernichten können das ist für sie
aber persönlicher auch eine erfahrung
die sie
in dieser zeit nämlich im bosnien krieg
damals als joschka fischer dieses farb-
attentat unterlief erlebt haben aber
haben sie jetzt im augenblick das gefühl
da ändert sich was ganz grundsätzlich
ist ich glaube schon wir haben ein
zivilisationsbruch der besonderen art
den wir momentan erleben aber schauen
sie ich habe den dienst mit der waffe
verweigert nicht wahr ich pazifistin und
pazifist war in der ddr sondern weil ich
nicht auf die menschen schießen wollten
die ddr verlassen haben oder die
versucht haben diese zum grenze zu
überwinden aber in bosnien habe ich
begriffen dass es ein recht gibt sich zu
wehren sich zu verteidigen
ich hatte zweifel gehabt ob das richtig
ist dass man das tut und ich hatte
damals sind für mich sehr hellen das
gespräch mit marek edelman den letzten
überlebenden kommandant des warschauer
ghetto aufstand ist und er hat zu mir
damals gesagt dass sie die junge mann
das einzige was wir gebraucht haben
damals waren waffen um uns zu
verteidigen wir wollten nicht so wie die
altvorderen in die waggons steigen uns
nach auschwitz abtransportieren zu
lassen sondern wir wollten zumindest in
würde uns verteidigen würde sterben und
das ist die situation von heute die
leute in sarajevo verteidigen sich das
hat sich bei mir tief eingebrannt und
ich glaube das ist eben auch die
situation in der ukraine
man setzt sich zur wehr diese menschen
kämpfen um ihre freiheit und sie
verteidigen auch unsere freiheit
diese erfahrung aus dem bosnien krieg
hat viele in ihrer einstellung so ein
bisschen durchgerüttelt muss man sagen
sie haben auschwitz erwähnt das hat
joschka fischer damals auch erwähnt in
diesem zusammenhang trotzdem ist das aus
dem blickfeld geraten und diese 90er
jahre schien dann weit weit weg zu sein
plötzlich und jetzt sagen viele wir sind
völlig überrascht über das was da
passiert ja bedauerlich ist das
irgendwie wieder in den hintergrund
ich weiß nicht warum man das vergessen
hat dieses nie wieder nie wieder krieg
nie wieder faschismus also manche haben
offenbar gedacht nie wieder krieg wenn
nie wieder von deutschen bodenkrieg
ausgeht dann sind wir da schon auf der
sicheren seite nein das ist nicht der
fall ich glaube man hat auch die
erfahrungen der alliierten vergessen die
als sie das greul in deutschland dann
festgestellt haben bei der auflösung der
konzentrationslager gesagt haben das war
zu spät und zu wenig was wir getan haben
wir hätten einiges verhindern müssen und
das ist im moment die situation wir
müssen das wieder ins bewusstsein rufen
wir haben das in unseren deutschen
wohlfühl
zustand offensichtlich vergessen dass
man diese demokratie wehrhaft
verteidigen muss dass man seine freiheit
verteidigen muss er notfalls wie wir
sehen sogar mit der waffe hinterhand es
gibt eine intensive diskussion in
deutschland über ja wir brauchen
schwerer waffen und müssen die auch
liefern und diejenigen die sagen nein da
müssen wir die große sorge haben dass
eskaliert zu sehr aber vielleicht vorher
nochmal die frage wenn das für sie auch
persönlich eine erfahrung in den 90er
jahren gewesen ist die heißt wir müssen
diese freiheit diese demokratie
verteidigen und im zweifelsfall auch mit
der waffe warum ist es trotzdem in
deutschland so unglaublich schwer an
kriegt noch mal zu akzeptieren zu
akzeptieren dass es kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen gibt auch in der
nähe und da auch die
notwendigkeit besteht einzugreifen
ich weiß nicht offensichtlich das gefühl
es betrifft uns nicht hier hat sich
dieses motor der
friedensbewegung der 70er 80er jahre
eingebrannt es stellt euch vor es ist
krieg und keiner geht hin und man hat
diesen kleinen konsequenten nachsatz
vergessen dann kommt der krieg zu uns
das ist im moment der fall der krieg
konnten serbe trifft uns wir konnten uns
wahrscheinlich gegen den bosnienkrieg
noch weitgehend stemmen wir haben einige
flüchtlinge hier erlebt wir haben was
wir glaube ich überhaupt nicht verdauen
denn verstanden haben wir hatten
aufgeklärte muslime gehabt in europa
also nicht eingefleischte salafisten
sondern in jugoslawien ex jugoslawien
haben sehr aufgeklärte muslime gelebt
diese community diese community ist
zerstört worden das haben wir hin
genommen ohne dass es hier große
kontrollen zum gehören auch hingenommen
werden gerufen wenn ich damals gesagt
habe die apu team kommt diese
flüchtlinge raus um europa zu
destabilisieren russland hat ja nicht
irgendwelche syrische flüchtlinge
aufgenommen niemand die wenigen die den
weg bis nach russland geschafft haben
hat man noch oft über die norwegische
grenze geschoben ein mann hat im grunde
genommen in syrien schon mal geübt den
großen krieg man hat die waffen getestet
man hat dort eingegriffen und hat diese
flüchtlinge eigentlich nach europa
gepumpt wenn wir das zur grundlage
machen würden was putin dort gemacht hat
er hat ja gesagt er hat streng nach dem
völkerrecht gehandelt also was hat hat
ihm zu hilfe gerufen und er hat im
grunde genommen eine rechtmäßig gewählte
regierung dort nur verteidigt gegen ihre
feinde gegen den es dann hätte sie
lenski alles recht uns zu hilfe zu rufen
das wäre der gleiche maßstab den putin
anlegt eine rechtmäßig demokratisch
gewählte regierung wird von einen
aggressor überfallen sie könnten
normalerweise aufs völkerrecht sich
berufen und uns zur hilfe rufen und
deswegen können wir auf jeden fall alle
möglichen arten von waffen liefern zur
selbstverteidigung
jetzt haben über den krieg gesprochen
und dieses gefühl der ablehnung das hat
mit uns eigentlich nichts zu tun das ist
doch eigentlich alles in den 90er jahren
in großer ruhe übergegangen alle werden
demokratisch freiheitlich mit
kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen haben
wir nichts mehr zu tun aber wir haben ja
noch einen anderen punkt wir haben
jemanden den wir möglicherweise ganz
falsch eingeschätzt haben sie
möglicherweise nicht denn sie haben 2014
in einem welt artikel geschrieben putin
ist derjenige der mit seinen kgb
genossen zusammen nach innen terror
ausübt um gegner zu beseitigen und nach
außen expansiv ist wie sind sie darauf
gekommen wie haben sie das
gefühlt oder gesehen ich habe putin
schon viel früher erkannt und gesehen
dass das ein wirklich skrupelloser kgb
offizier ist der an die spitze in
russland gekommen ist schauen sie die
berühmte legendäre rede 2001 im
bundestag ich habe drei tage zuvor
zusammen mit meinem kollegen helmut
lippelt einen brief an ihn geschrieben
den haben wir den russischen botschafter
in berlin übergeben und haben den
präsident putin aufgefordert wenn er
schon im hohen haus reden kann dann möge
er bitte zu diesen barbarischen
schrecklichen krieg in tschetschenien
stellung nehmen zu diesen
menschenrechtsverletzungen die dort
stattfinden wir wussten dass von unseren
freunden aus der russischen opposition
ich sage nur anna politkowskaja die sich
ja sehr mit diesem krieg beschäftigt
hatten auch mit den
aspekten wie dieser krieg überhaupt
zustande gekommen ist wer vom zaun
gebrochen worden ist das ist ja auch
eine geschichte wo der fsb also der
geheimdienst beteiligt war putin hat
darauf nicht reagiert ich habe das
plenum verlassen ich war entsetzt als es
dann standing ovations gab also meine
kollegen diesen mann gefeiert haben sie
haben ihn praktisch wie einen enkel
gorbatschows begrüßt und sie haben nicht
den ziehsohn des kgb es erkannt das war
schon damals eine große täuschung dieser
mann ist grube los eiskalt und setzt
seine vorstellung mit gewalt um aber es
gibt ja nur zwei
sagen wir mal gründe dafür mann ist
möglicherweise blauäugig gewesen das war
eine schöne vision da hatten wir
wladimir putin der setzte genau diese
von gorbatschow initiierte
friedens situation fort es kann aber
noch auch sein dass man ein anderes
verhältnis immer zu
moskau zu russland gehabt hat er schon
gerade sie als ostdeutsche haben haben
deutsche ein anderes verhältnis es gibt
andere nationen die sind sehr viel
distanzierter immer gewesen ja aber
schauen sie das streckt jemand die hand
aus und sagt der kalte krieg ist beendet
aber es zu diesem zeitpunkt ein
kriegstreiber diese hand ist blutig
gewesen er hat einen blutigen krieg in
schweden ist das denn nicht aufgefallen
das müssen sie die kollegen fragen die
da aufgestanden und standing ovations
ich hab das nicht mehr verstanden ich
habe dann draußen gesagt wem habt ihr
denn hier applaudiert ihr diesen krieg
in tschetschenien nicht seht ihr nicht
was dieser mann macht der zerstört die
demokratie
er ist momentan gerade dabei ein neues
system das was ihm gefällt aufzubauen
russland man konnte all die folgenden
dinge die dann passiert sind noch nicht
in dieser scheußlichkeit erkennen aber
das ist ja dann im einzelnen passiert
nein er hat im grunde genommen ich kann
ihnen ja erzählen wie wir in dresden
beispielsweise als kgb
oberstleutnant verhindert hat dass die
kgb akten gesichert wurden also am
sechsten dezember 1989 gehen meine
freunde vom neuen forum und
besetzen das stasi gebäude um die stasi
akten zu sichern und sagen wir gehen
rüber zum kgb um auch die kgb akten zu
sichern da tritt in der oberstleutnant
putin mit gezogener pistole entgegen und
sagt er ist offizier der roten armee und
er wird dieses objekt hier verteidigen
danach hat er sich der brand höfen
besorgt dann würden diese kgb akten in
dresden verbrannt er hat das immer als
offensichtlich faschistischen spuk
eingeschätzt dass dieses system der ddr
zusammenbrechen war übrigens eins seiner
traumata dass ein felsenfest sicher
geglaubtes system durch straßenproteste
gestutzt werden kann das hat sich dann
immer wieder holt die orangen revolution
die rosenrevolution in georgien das war
für ihn immer indizien dass wenn die
leute auf der straße sind dieses
totalitäre system gestürzt werden
könnten und das ist ja das was wir in
den letzten jahren immer wieder erlebt
haben bei der demonstration gegen die
mit massiver gewalt vorgegangen worden
ist und eigentlich gibt es ja dann auch
tote oppositionelle muss man mal brutal
sagen oder oppositionelle die im
gefängnis sitzen wiener wahlen die die
eigentlich auch kaum eine zukunft haben
sie waren mit nemtsov der auf der brücke
zum roten platz ermordet worden ist sehr
eng befreundet was haben sie über
russland über die russische situation
damals erfahren also ich habe nimsoft
damals nicht viel aufgeholt besucht als
er noch gouverneur war weil die russen
hatten brauchte ich die privatisierung
so durchgeführt wie wir uns das am
runden tisch vorgestellt hatten wir
wollten ja das volkseigentum verteilen
damit jeder so eine kapital teilhabe uhr
konnte bekommt also ein stück von
volkseigentum
das ist dann ganz anders gelaufen das
kam ja alles in deutschland in die
treuhand und die treuhand hat diese
privatisierung durchgeführt aber in
russland hat man solche watcher
ausgeteilt also die leute hatten
praktischen teil des volkseigentums
viele haben das dann für einen appel und
ein ei verkauft weil die ernährungslage
in den 90er jahren sehr sehr schlecht
war aber boris nemzow hatte das in
nischni nowgorod relativ gut geschafft
er hat also dort einen sagen wir mal
funktionierenden mittelstand aufgebaut
das hat mich interessiert wir sind dazu
wir sind freunde geworden und ich habe
ihn für einen
unglaublichen staatsmann gehalten er hat
ja dann war dann stellvertretender
ministerpräsident unter boris jelzin der
war eigentlich der nachfolger von boris
jelzin wenn nicht gerade man jemand
gebraucht hätte der diese
korruptionsaffäre beenden konnte und das
war eben der geheimdienstchef putin den
mann dann eingesetzt hat man hat sich in
ihm getäuscht denn der hat diese
silowiki nachgeholt also seine genossen
vom kgb und aus den bewaffneten organe
heute sehen sie in allen möglichen
positionen russland sind es ehemalige
geheimdienstoffiziere die das sagen
haben der geheimdienst hat diesen staat
übernommen
wir haben in deutschland eine starke
diskussion darüber ob man schwere waffen
liefern soll oder ob man aus sorge um
einen atomkrieg sich zurückhalten soll
wie beurteilen sie die diskussion macht
das sinn in der deutschen gesellschaft
darüber zu diskutieren wir sind eine
demokratie man braucht diesen diskurs
aber wie sehen sie die beiden positionen
also wir brauchen den diskurs aber wird
dürfen das handeln nicht vergessen denn
die ukraine ist im kampf sie müssen sich
verteidigen und sie können nicht warten
bis wir die sache aus diskutiert haben
was man braucht wir müssen der ukraine
all das zur verfügung stellen was sie
brauchen wenn wir selbst schon dort
keinen einsatz leisten normalerweise
würde uns das völkerrecht das hergeben
dass wir dort eingreifen das tun wir
nicht aus bekannten gründen
wir dürfen uns auch von der atom
drohungen nicht einschüchtern lassen ich
warte immer noch auf denjenigen der den
mumm hat hier in europa mal zu sagen
mein lieber putin womit du trost ist ein
selbstmord und der kollektive selbst
mutter eines landes deiner bevölkerung
denn wer zuerst den knopf drückt wird
als zweiter sterben das ist ja die
bekannte regel aus dem gleichgewicht der
kräfte wenn es zum atomschlag kommen
würde das ist eine leere drohung die
dieser mann ausstößt und die dürfen wir
nicht annehmen dürfen wir vor allen
dingen nicht verlängern er wird sich das
nicht trauen weil er natürlich weiß dass
er den kürzeren zieht wenn er das
wirklich tun würde weil so mächtig ist
russland nicht sie sind ja noch noch
nicht mal in der lage diesen
konventionellen krieg offensichtlich zu
gewinnen sind sie sind ja festgefahren
momentan in der ukraine wir haben eine
militärparade erlebt bei der die sorge
bestand die erwartung bestand da werden
jetzt waffen gezeigt übrigens auch
dieses berühmte flugzeug das über lebens
flugzeug was bei einem atomangriff im
zweifelsfall sich noch einmal für eine
zeit sagen aus der situation heraus
halten kann von einer kommandozentrale
könnte dann putin weiter regieren
da ist aber nicht sehr viel passiert
diese flugzeuge sind nicht gezeigt
wurden die rede von putin ist sehr
zurückhaltend gewesen
wir haben sie die empfunden also wir
können ja den begriff der portieren
clinton dörfer das ist ja eine russische
erfindung dass man fassaden aufstellt wo
dahinter nichts ist und ich glaube auch
hier bei dieser militärtechnik poseidon
das ist so ein unterwasser torpedo
könnte man ganz england versenken das
sind alles solche kraftmeierischen
preußischen militär
aussagen die ich in zweifel ziehen würde
ich glaube nicht dass russland dieses
potenzial hat und vor allen dingen sie
werden es nicht einsetzen weil es ist
der kollektives selbstmord wenn man das
einsetzen würde das wissen wir doch aus
dem gleichgewicht des schreckens die
erste atomrakete die fliegt würde eine
vielzahl von gegen raketen auslösen das
würde russland nicht überstehen und ich
hoffe dass es dort genügend vernünftige
leute gibt es ist jan drei koffer
prinzip das kann also nicht nur putin
alleine auslösen dass es da immer noch
ein jemand gibt in dieser kette der die
vernunft hat zu sagen um gottes willen
wir wollen ja hier nicht drauf gehen wir
sind ja nicht im führerbunker und neben
ein ganzes volk noch mehr man hat aber
nur ein entzieht man hat aber manchmal
so ein bisschen den eindruck das ist so
eine führer bunkermentalität denn viele
sagen ja er hat eigentlich nur noch
diejenigen um sich geschart die zu 100
prozent hinter ihm stehen oder die sorge
haben dass er gegen sie massiv vorgeht
wenn wir von der situation ausgehen wie
könnte denn eigentlich eine lage
entstehen in der putin die macht
verliert schwer zu sagen ich glaube wenn
dieser krieg nicht so ausgeht wie das
was er versprochen hat also dass er die
ukraine überwältigt und in einer
gewissen weise einverleiben kann sind
seine aktien ziemlich schlecht es seine
position ziemlich schlecht er ist nicht
mehr der starke mann wenn dieser krieg
nicht so ausgeht wie er das erhofft hat
also die entsprechende land gewinnen und
die faktisch angeblich faschistische
runter da in kiew gestützt werden kann
wie das in russland weiter geht das kann
im moment glaube ich keiner genau sagen
ich sehe keine gegenkräfte die ihnen die
ihn stürzen würden aber wie ist das
immer in russland gewesen diese macht
übergänge sind häufig gewaltsam gewesen
also gross scharf ist nur zum zuge
gekommen weil man bürger beseitigt hat
und die anderen mitglieder im politbüro
hamm stalin regelrecht verrecken lassen
sie haben keine hilfe geleistet also
die geschichte ist eine sehr gewaltsame
in russland und ich glaube putin hat
eben nichts gutes zu befürchten nichts
gutes zu erwarten wenn er abtritt
deswegen versucht er sich auch an der
macht zu halten und versucht so lange
wie möglich präsident zu bleiben wir zu
viele leichen im keller es muss ich sie
aber als einen der ganz prominenten von
bündnis 90/die grünen großer parteitag
1993 in leipzig fragen ob sie ihre
eigene partei noch wiedererkennen wir
haben ja in deutschland inzwischen einer
situation in der die außenministerin
baerbock und ein wirtschaftsminister
habeck die spd schon überholt haben die
sind viel dynamischer viel
fortschrittlicher während die spd in
vielen fragen unter anderem auch in der
frage von waffenlieferungen et cetera
noch diskutiert erkennen sie ihre
parteien auch wieder ja sehr wohl also
ich finde vor allem die entwicklung ist
wichtig gewesen wie wir uns entwickelt
haben wir haben uns allmählich dahin
entwickeln es waren ja durchaus sehr
schweren zerreißende und spannende
diskussionen die wir geführt haben das
hat keine andere partei in der weise und
in der tiefe damals in den 90er jahren
geführt werden das war wirklich nicht
leicht gemacht und insofern ist
diese entwicklung jetzt zu sehen in der
partei
annalena baerbock robert habeck hätten
nicht diese position wenn wir nicht die
grundsätzlichen fragen in den neunziger
jahren schon ausdiskutiert hätten und
sie handeln jetzt konsequent ich hatte
bedenken noch gehabt vor dem 24 februar
ich habe einen offenen brief an die
regierungsmitglieder der bündnisgrünen
geschrieben am 22
habe sie daraufhin diesen dass wir
durchaus waffen liefern können weil ja
immer die behauptung war wir können
keine waffen in krisengebiete liefern
und habe sie darauf hingewiesen dass es
die politischen exportrichtlinien gibt
der bundesregierung wo ausdrücklich
steht wir liefern nicht in krisengebiete
aber ausnahme artikel 51 uno-charta
waffen zur selbstverteidigung das heißt
wir hätten längst waffen liefern müssen
denn seit 2014 gab es diesen krieg im
don bosco brigens auch die jetzt einen
brief geschrieben haben dass wir keine
schweren waffen liefern sollten das hat
sie damals nicht interessiert dass der
schwere waffen in den donots gekommen
sind plötzlich hatten die seperatisten
schwerer waffen haben ein zivilflugzeug
die emh 17 abgeschossen mit 300
passagieren
da hat das niemand interessiert mit den
schweren waffen da gab es einen aufruf
oder ein brief wieder krieg in europa
fragezeichen ausrufezeichen nicht in
unserem namen ich habe dann einen
artikel geschrieben mit der überschrift
lasst uns mit krieg in frieden das war
die haltung der deutschen angeblichen
pazifisten mann hatte sich sehr bequem
eingerichtet man wollte von diesem krieg
nichts wissen aber dann muss ich mal
wissen wie sie die
affinität zu dieser russischen seele die
es angeblich gibt denn sehen es wird ja
im augenblick auch sehr klar dass es
sehr unterschiedliche strömungen in der
deutschen bevölkerung gibt nicht nur
politisch sondern auch emotional es gibt
ja immer wieder den hinweis eigentlich
sind die uns doch relativ nah wir haben
doch eine besondere verbindung zu
russland erleben sie das vor allen
dingen auch in den ostdeutschen ländern
also es gibt dort glaube ich eine
größere zustimmung zu putin als in den
westdeutschen bundesländern das kann man
feststellen das betrifft aber vor allen
dingen so dass harte klientel der pegi
die anhänger der querdenker der im
verweigerung so weiter das ist eine sehr
komplizierte sache das zu erklären wie
das zusammenhängt nicht nur weil man
russisch sozialisiert wurden es in der
ddr und im dadurch sowjetischen
freundschaft war oder sowas oder
russisch gelernt hat und es heute nicht
kann das muss man ja dazu sagen viele
jahre lang russisch gelernt und hatten
keine große affinität zu dieser sprache
also können das nicht aber es gibt so
ein t shirt beispielsweise das steht in
kyrillisch darauf wird das nicht lesen
kann ist ein wessi das ist sehr
aufschlussreich also man hat plötzlich
etwas wo man meint man ist im westen
überlegen wir können etwas was der west
ja alles kann nicht kann wir können uns
das ja erinnert deutsche es ist ein
innerdeutsches problem und dann kommt
hinzu putin drückt einen phantomschmerz
aus ja sagt putin ihr habt uns was
weggenommen habt uns die ukraine
weggenommen ihr habt uns georgien
weggenommen und ihr habt uns das was mal
sowjetunion war weggenommen das ist bei
den ostdeutschen ähnlich ja die haben
auch das gefühl gehabt durch der messe
hat uns was weggenommen die treue die
hat uns das weggenommen dann kommt
dieser kultur kampf dazu das muss man
auch beachten dieser schwule dekadente
vegane westen so praktisch mit seinem
sender gaga und sowas putin an greift
also diese ganze lebensort wir sind noch
hier der echte mann der ist in russland
nur der darf seine frau erschlagen oder
sowas und homosexualität etwas perverses
und dagegen wir vor und das sind ja
eigentlich kennzeichen von faschismus
oder er selber ich sage ja wir müssen
den faschismus blick ja natürlich es ist
es ist es ist der blanke faschismus den
berlin es ist nicht nur nationalismus es
ist evident ismus den wir vorher erlebt
haben also das wieder einverleiben von
ländern wo eine minderheit lebt also das
was hitler mit mit dem sudetenland
gemacht hat also wir müssen unsere
landsleute die woanders leben im donbass
das war ja die begründung mit 700.000
russische pässe ausgeteilt auf der krim
besser ausgeteilt und dann hat man
gesagt dass er unsere landsleute die
müssen wir schützen weil die bösen
ukraine und die wollen sie verdrängen
und dürfen ihre sprache nicht mehr reden
das sind alles propaganda lügen das ist
ein klassisches repertoire des
faschismus was wir ersucht sich bei den
russischen philosophen und den
russischen historikern eine eigene
vorstellung von der welt brechen
zusammen ist immer wieder der forschung
können sie das na ja und natürlich du
gehn und solche philosophen die er
zusammen glaubt hat er hat ja auch so
geklettert das geschichtsbild ja das ist
so versatzstücken und bisschen stalin
und bis zum russischen nationalismus vor
der bolschewiki aber eigentlich immer
die großmacht er möchte großmacht sein
er möchte als großmacht akzeptiere ich
das ist das eine sache die mit seiner
person seiner psyche zu tun könnte
möglich sein der hat ja dieses dieses
trauma wie gesagt dass da was
zusammengestürzt ist was er für
felsenfest sicher geglaubt hat er kommt
von ganz unten er musste sich
durchbeißen er spricht diese russische
ganoven sprache das ist ja furchtbar was
er sagt also oppositionelle sind
abschaum das wie eine fliege die in den
mund kommt die man ausspucken muss da
sagte russisch oder in tschetschenien
leider gesagt man muss dem viehzeug die
google und drehen das ist russische
ganoven sprache kommt aber beim teil der
leute gut an das ist einer von uns der
haut mal mit der faust auf den tisch der
kredit klartext oder sowas würde man in
deutschland sagen dass das macht ihnen
nur gewissen weise populär man liebt den
starken mann in russland ja also was was
heißt die russische seele es gibt den
ausspruch russland kann man nicht
verstehen dann russland muss man glauben
oder so etwas das ist eine merkwürdige
sache dass bedient er sehr stark und er
hat die opposition natürlich
auf die seite gedrängt notfalls eben
auch die leute umbringen lassen
wenn wir noch mal zurückkommen auf diese
angebliche affinität sie haben es ja
beschrieben wodurch die möglicherweise
entsteht in ostdeutschland ist das etwas
was im zweifelsfall auch einen gewissen
reiz ausübt einen reiz ausübt weil auch
faschismus einen reiz ausübt das sind so
bestimmte merkmale
auch dieses starke dieses gewalttätige
all diese geschichten die auch in
russland sie haben es gerade erwähnt
eine durchaus anziehende wirkung haben
das funktioniert aber doch bei der
jugend nicht mehr so richtig das sind
doch ganz ganz viele jetzt auch aus
russland rausgegangen wie funktioniert
denn ein solches riesenreich dana die
jugend läuft weg die intellektuelle
jugend also das humankapital was dieses
land eigentlich braucht und das ist
tragisch die die verlassen das land das
sind viele intelligente gut gebildete
menschen die russland verlassen ja aber
auf ostdeutschland bezogen das
autoritäre an putin ist das anziehen der
der starke mann also in dresden ruft man
putin kommen hilf uns oder so wie früher
hätten die berufe helmut kohl kommen und
hilf uns also dieses paternalistische
man man sucht nach der starken figur da
oben in russland ist das natürlich sehr
ausgeprägt da ist jeder ansatz von
demokratie stecken geblieben also die
bolschewiki hat schon eine demokratische
revolution
zurückgetreten an sich bolschewiki und
waren eine minderheit eine handvoll von
berufsrevolutionär die die menschen
wirklich auf die seite geschoben haben
danach ist ein totalitäres stilistisches
system aufgebaut worden die paar wenigen
jahre demokratie und der bus nimmt er
unter boris jelzin sind im grunde
genommen er als wirtschaftlich
bedrückend wahrgenommen worden da konnte
putin dann immer darauf zurückgreifen
konnte sagen wollt ihr wieder leben wie
den 90er jahren der ölpreis ging hoch er
hatte geld und konnte wohltaten
ausschütten da wo er auftaucht wird man
eine sporthalle gebaut oder dies oder
jenes gemacht wird das ist also die die
fast zaristische art und weise dieses
land zu regieren mit zuckerbrot und
peitsche sie haben von potente dritten
gesprochen ja in diesem artikel
von 2014
wie könnte denn eine lösung aussehen sie
haben ja jetzt eine sehr starre
herrschaft beschrieben eine herrschaft
die auch jede art von gewalt in kauf
nimmt um die herrschaft zu behalten
die auch eine gewisse faszination
ausübt aber wie könnte eine lösung denn
aussehen
das ist die
millionen dollar frage ich kann ihnen
das nicht genau sagen ich habe nur die
geschichtliche erfahrung dass in
russland das volk lange zeit sehr
geduldiges und dann gibt es plötzlich
eine explosionsartige entladung also
revolution gab es dort immer wieder
blutige aufstände innerhalb des systems
rasputin der dort sein unwesen getrieben
haben jetzt haben wir mit einem gast
putin zu tun der ebenfalls die das
politisch das ganze macht es könnte sich
innerhalb des kremls ereignen das
allerdings muss uns nicht unbedingt
positiv stimmen weil es könnten genauso
schlimmer hardliner die macht übernehmen
ich sehe da kaum liberale kräfte aber es
ist durchaus möglich dass dieses volk
wenn es mitbekommt was man für einen
brutalen krieg geführt hat nicht mehr zu
bändigen ist man muss sich einmal
anschauen warum ist boris nemzow form
gebracht worden wo es nimsoft
informationen gesammelt über den krieg
im don was die soldaten mütter haben ihm
zugetragen wer dort gefallen ist es
durften die leute ja nicht offiziell
beerdigt werden konnten keine trauer
anzeigen geschaltet werden das dürfte
auf die grabsteine nichts gebracht
werden das musste alles irgendwie
verdeckt ablaufen aber die soldaten
mütter haben es oft mit informationen
versorgt und er hat im grunde genommen
zusammengestellt welche einheiten dort
kämpfen also nicht freiwillige die im
urlaub mit ihren waffen dahin gegangen
sind sondern reguläre einheit mit diesem
material war er vorher bei einem
radiosender und wollte das auch alles
veröffentlicht wir haben das material
ist gesichert worden aber auf dem
rückweg von diesem radiosender mit dem
interview so wie ich es jetzt mit ihnen
führer in einem freien land
soeben auf der brücke vom kreml
erschossen worden das hat man als
bedrohung erkannt weil es gibt von
jewgeni jewtuschenko dass das wunderbare
gedicht meinst du die russen wollen
krieg das glaube ich nicht die russen
wollen keinen krieg aber ihr präsident
führt einen schrecklichen krieg und wenn
das ins bewusstsein dringt was man dort
angetan hat einen bruder volkmann ist ja
mit den ukrainern und eigentlich
brüderlich verbunden ich glaube das wird
das wird noch auswirkungen haben nach
scholz' ganz herzlichen dank dass sie
bei mir waren und war sehr spannend
dankeschön
[Musik]